just 16 miles north of athens the fire
has subsided
but the bone-dry land is smoldering
and threatens to flare up again do you
want a hand
as we check out the damage a tree
reignites
just meters from someone's home
environmental scientist constantinos
calls it in but resources are stretched
to their limits
and when it comes to climate change
patience is wearing thin
we are very worried about what we are
seeing as we are every summer actually
we're getting fires as part of our
ecosystem in the mediterranean and in
greece but
year after year they're getting all the
worser because of climate change it
aggravates temperatures summer is
getting drier
and the governments and the services are
getting less and less competent to
manage the phenomena
more than 20 countries have now sent
support to join the firefighting effort
in greece
this team from france arrived on
thursday but have no idea
if they'll be here for weeks even months
[Music]
some of the fires have been blamed on
arson and negligence
but the extreme temperatures also follow
a trend
of global warming thousands of acres
have now burned
thousands of homes remain abandoned and
with 45 degree heat
forecast here once again there's a very
real
fear fires will return in the coming
days
and years sally lock with sky news
athens